JAKE ARCHIBALD: This is
one of the things that's
changed on the web
since the start days
for me is you now need to set
up a server to do anything.
It used to be that you could
just run the stuff on your file
system.
That doesn't work anymore
because the cross-origin rules
have been, quite rightly,
really tightened up in browsers.
Like if you're on
the file system,
you can't really
contact anything else.
It's all treated as a
separate origin, which
it should be, right,
because you don't want a web
page on your machine being
able to go into your passwords
folder or whatever.
But that's it.
If you get started
with web, all you
need is an HTTP server running
on local host and off you go.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
No.
Again, no.
Always no with you.
Right.
Fine.
It works on your
machine, and then you
upload it to your server
and it goes, ha ha, no,
because it's no longer HTTPS.
I've white listed local
hosts so you're good to go,
but now, it should be Service
Worker, push notifications,
all those lovely new
things you wanted, uh-uh.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Paul
hates security on the web.
PAUL LEWIS: Again, HTTPS
is just too difficult
and there's so many features
being gated on HTTPS right
now that it's a bit depressing.
You know, why?
Tell me the answer.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: HTTPS
is super important.
I think if there are two
sources of information that
are otherwise completely equal
and completely identical,
except on one of
them, you can trust
that you'll receive
it unmodified,
course that's better.
PAUL LEWIS: I'm OK with it
from the user perspective.
It's a good thing
to ship for users.
But-- but-- it's not--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Button.
PAUL LEWIS: Button.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: He's going to
press the serious button now.
This is your disapproval button.
PAUL LEWIS: This is the--
aargh-- the rage button.
Because the hosting
that you get is not
going to give you that by
default. It's too hard, right?
If you go into DevOps and
you run your own server,
you're by proxy saying,
this is something
I am willing to take on as
my responsibility, right?
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Yeah.
PAUL LEWIS: OK?
But if you don't, and
the standard issue
developer that I am, I don't
want to get into DevOps.
I don't want to do that.
I think the default option
from my host should be HTTPS.
It shouldn't even
be a thing that I
have to opt into when
they go, you get PHP 4, 5,
MySQL, as many
[INAUDIBLE] as you
want, oh, and you get SSL
just by default because you're
a human being who wanted
to get hosting from us.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I
think the big companies
such as Google, they
need to find a way to,
rather than punishing
the developer,
they punish the hosts.
Because there's a lot of
hosts still using HTTPS
as a money spinner, whereas
with things like SNI,
it can be super cheap.
OK, with SNI, you
lose Android 2.
Android 2 doesn't support it.
And you also lose Internet
Explorer on XP, I think.
But those things are going away.
It should just be free, as
you say, with every host.
PAUL LEWIS: HTTP at
this point, for me,
should be more like a bug.
It should be considered-- aah.
That's--
JAKE ARCHIBALD: Now,
there's been some discussion
around that and there's
been some people suggesting
that all new web
features should only
land on HTTPS, whether it's
security sensitive or not.
I disagree with
that quite strongly.
PAUL LEWIS: I think if 95% of
the web was HTTPS, fair enough,
but it's not.
I think we've got to get
more people as the default
before you start switching
things off properly.
I can see the new features,
the ones that are security
sensitive particularly.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: I think
it's fine for security
sensitive stuff.
Service Worker is HTTPS
only for a good reason.
We tried to find a way to
make it work with HTTP.
There wasn't a way.
But for features
that don't need it,
like we're getting
a new media API.
So the Play, Pause keys on
your lock screen and stuff,
we're going to bring
those to the web.
That doesn't need HTTPS.
PAUL LEWIS: No.
I mean, it would be
ludicrous if somebody said,
WebGL or IndexDB,
they require HTTPS
because they're on the web.
It doesn't make sense.
JAKE ARCHIBALD: It
does sort of feel
like the standards people
wagging their fingers
at developers going,
eat your greens
or you're not allowed
the pudding, where
the greens are HTTPS and the
pudding is new web features.
I don't think it's
a constructive way
to build up the web.
[MUSIC PLAYING]